this week's episode is brought to you in
part by the ad a teeth tell a story we
know what ancient civilizations ate
drank even where they lived all from
looking at their teeth what story will
your teeth tell about you your ad a
dentist can help you find out and give
you the tools to keep your teeth healthy
for years to come
use the American Dental Association's
find a dentist tool to find the right
dentist for you go to a DA org slash
science bag today this week's episode is
brought to you in part by Startalk
Allstars in a world filled with fake
news flat earthers and conspiracy
theories
what's a thinking person to do think
like a skeptic of course on last week's
episode of star talk all stars
neuroscientist Heather Berlin and her
comic co-host
Ari Shaffir investigated the importance
of skeptical thinking with their guests
Cara Santa Maria and Steven novella of
the skeptics guide to the universe
remember trust no one
question authority and listen to
Startalk all stars wherever you listen
to podcast for the rigorous scientific
thinking you crave
welcome to the science podcast for
November 23rd 2018 I'm Sarah press B on
this week's show Megan Cantwell talks
with news writer Josh Sokol about a
fossil excavation site that's helping
crack the Cambrian explosion this is
this incredible period of
diversification of life that started
about 540 million years ago and I talked
with James hazel about his Policy Forum
that proposes a universal DNA database
for law enforcement would that be better
than the public and private genetic
databases in use today I'm Megan
Cantwell and I'm here with science
writer Joshua Sokol to talk about his
story cracking the cambrian which delves
into life over 500 million years into
the past
hey Josh hey you got to join
paleontologists on this really cool
expedition to a fossil excavation site
in the Kootenai National Park in British
Columbia Canada so what was it like
watching this process of fossils being
excavated it's just incredibly scenic to
be there campsite itself is extremely
remote you know a four or five hour hike
if you were to get there on foot you
walk from there to the quarry which is a
tiny area on a very steep cliff and the
whole process is they've identified the
rock layers that they want to look at
they're gonna break big slabs out cut
the slabs up and then they'll all
distribute them around and have
individual paleontologists chipping them
open with chisels and each time they
break one open there's the chance that
inside they'll be some sort of amazing
arthropod or fossil that no one's ever
seen before it's remarkable to see these
animals being dug out and to see the
gears spinning in the mind of the
paleontologists moving at it and trying
to say what living animal created this
how could I reconstruct them how are
they related to any animal that lives
today the creatures that they're finding
lived in the ocean around 500 million
years ago but the fossils excavated were
up high on this mountain how do they end
up there five hundred and seven or so
million years ago what's now almost near
the top of a mountain was a shallow sea
there's been just enormous kind of
geologic upheavals since then and Oh
Rodney which geologists call
Mountain Formation process push these up
to where they are now where they're
peeking out at the side of a mountain
now it's just really cool to see and
there are a bunch of places where these
Falls outcrop throughout the mountains
here the fossils were discovered in a
site specifically called well the unit
is called the Burgess Shale and this is
a unit of rocks that researchers have
been unearthing fossils from for decades
so why is this unit so great for
excavating fossils from what about it is
so special that brings people back the
unique thing about the Burgess Shale is
what was originally that this was the
best preservation site for this period
and all of these historic discoveries
were made there the recent discovery
though that this formation extends is
cool he goes for miles throughout this
mountain range and you can pick
different outcroppings of it but what
they found and what makes them come back
is that when you go to different
locations along this mountain range
different burgess shale areas there's
going to be different species there's
gonna be different animal communities
there and so that gives enormous
ecological value to understanding not
just what one ecosystem would like
during this period but a set of
different ecosystems what about the
specific site you visited was kind of
interesting or unique then so this year
there's a unidentified arthropod fossil
that hasn't been described and it looks
very vaguely like a spaceship so that's
what the team calls it and now until
they kind of devise a scientific name
for it and it's just an animal that's
not known from other Cambrian sites even
than the burger sale but this summer
they found for the first time and they
didn't just find one they found it all
over the place it's incredibly common
the paleontologists you quoted said it
was the most extraordinary fossil which
means it should be pretty special right
yeah yes so they were finding these sort
of spaceships all the time and they
found this one exceptional example just
huge and intact and looks slightly
different from the others and so the
team of course calls this the mothership
the spaceships are the smaller ones and
the mothership is the big perfect one
why was there so much animal diversity
during this time period is that
something that they've gotten more
answers to as they've explored this site
there's sort of a global picture which
is forming around this site the fact
that it's a different location than the
original burgess shale location and the
fact that also paleontologists have
found other
locations that are really important for
finding fossils from this period around
the world one school of thought which is
that this is a biological revolution
where all these groups exist and there's
another one that says this is partly
we're biased because this is a fossil
issue the fact that suddenly all of
these things were fossilized wall so any
explanation for the caiman explosion has
to involve both these things to what
extent were the animals dispersing and
spreading and diverting the different
groups and to what extent also was that
preserved so well that it lasts over 500
million years later and we can study the
individual species how the fossils
specifically from the burgess shale
changed our understanding of evolution
and animal life are there certain
lineages you can see from these fossils
that trace back to animal life in this
day the major fossils in the burgess
shale and the major fossil northland
Cambrian the most common group the most
diverse group are the arthropods which
today you see insects and crustaceans
and crustaceans dominate the oceans
insects dominate the land they're so
diverse but their diversity is only a
fraction of the diversity kind of
disparity between of animals that
existed in the Cambrian so one thing the
British shell shows is all of the
different pan arthropods the things that
we wouldn't even consider modern-day
arthropods but that were even weirder
and stranger the evolution kind of tried
and then ultimately those groups died
out the other thing that's in the
Burgess Shale that's really remarkable
our early chordates animals with the
sort of a proto spine so our vertebrate
ancestors are reflected in this valley
in a sense when we look at this we're
looking at the origin of all of the most
diverse and successful groups on earth
including our own are these conditions
also found in other places around the
world are we seeing more sites that
reflect this Cambrian explosion so
paleontologists believe that it's not an
accident that there are so many amazing
Cambrian fossils that preserve soft
details what do you mean by soft details
that are preserved these fossils have
amazing things they feature not just
hard skeletons but they have the eyes
the guts
they have nervous systems in some cases
there are certain exceptional fossils
that seem to preserve brains
neurons from animals that lived over
half a billion years ago so it's really
remarkable and these are actually
higher-quality fossils than exist from
almost any other time in the history of
the earth it's kind of a weird paradox
they're the oldest some of the oldest
animals but they're some of the best
preserve one of the major theories is
that there were sort of worldwide
chemical conditions that made the
Cambrian very conducive to producing
good fossils so imagine animals are
dying they're falling into a muddy sea
floor and there's not a lot of nutrients
there for bacteria that would typically
decompose them so the bodies are left
pretty intact and the ocean chemistry is
such that each layer of mud gets sealed
and cemented off very quickly so it's
just sealed into rock quickly the
animals are preserved this could explain
why there's not just amazing fossils
from the burgess shale but also amazing
Kameron fossils from from other
locations that have been discovered in
the last few decades is there a lot of
momentum right now in the research
community to explore more of the
Cambrian and I know in your piece you
mentioned that there are others study
sites in China that are being explored
as well there are a lot of sort of new
fossil localities that the biggest one
that's been developed in the last few
decades is in China where it's very
accessible and they're sort of rival
teams compete to find new Cambrian
fossils and to find the exceptional ones
the ones that really show you how these
animals tick describing these bizarre
animals and where they fitted the Tree
of Life nest the scientists who do this
high-profile publications and then
there's the deeper sort of evolutionary
mysteries as to why all these groups
seem to jump into the fossil record at
this time they excavated many tons
during that session I went to and people
have been going to the Canadian Rockies
and doing this for over a century and in
China there's excavations probably going
on right this second the vast majority
these fossils they get analyzed that
gets stored but there's a great chance
that people going back through the
collections and looking to answer
specific questions can find new things
that the original people who dug the
fossils out didn't even anticipate thank
you so much Josh Thank You Joshua so
coal is a science journalist based in
Boston you can find a link to his story
at science magic slash podcasts
next up Sarah Krusty talks with
researcher James hazel about the right
way to set up a DNA database for
forensic purposes this week's episode is
also brought to you by opps Jeannie
incidents happen and they require
complex coordination between operations
and software development teams who are
putting out fires every day that's why
getting alerts immediately is critical
thankfully there's ops Jeannie bile a
cien ops Jeannie empowers dev and ops
teams to plan for service disruptions
and stay in control during incidents it
also gives teams the power to respond
quickly and efficiently to unplanned
issues and helps to notify all the right
people through a smart combination of
scheduling and escalation paths that
account for things like time zones and
holidays better yet ops Jeannie allows
for deep flexibility and how when and
where alerts are deployed with over 200
integrations like JIRA Amazon CloudWatch
data dog New Relic and more plus it
tracks all activity and provides useful
insights to improve future incident
responses with offs Jeannie your next
incident doesn't stand a chance
visit ops Jeannie comm to sign up to get
a free company account and add up to
five team members that's ops Jeannie
calm o-p-s GE n comm never miss a
critical or again with ops Jeannie
[Music]
this episode is also brought to you by
bombas thanks to two years of research
and development multiple improvements
and design performance and comfort
bombo's are the most comfortable socks
in the history of feet with an arch
support system that provides extra
support where you need it most and a
cushioned footbed that's reinforced for
comfort without added bulkiness bombas
feel like a hug around your foot
not to mention bombas stay up technology
ensures your socks stay in place without
leaving a mark and the supersoft cotton
material makes you never want to take
them off so whether you're a runner
Walker
lounger there's a pair of bombas that'll
add comfort to your life go to bombas
comm slash science mag and use the code
science mag to get 20% off your first
order
that's bombas vom das comm slash science
bag code science mag and you'll get 20%
off your first order now we have James
hazel a researcher working on the use of
DNA in forensics he's here to talk to us
about the case for a universal DNA
forensics database I'm Sarah Crespi hi
James hey Sara thanks for having me
sure so we don't have anything like this
now we have government databases of DNA
we have public databases of DNA and
private databases like ancestry or
23andme all with very different people
inside of them and also different access
rights so how does law enforcement use
these types of databases right now that
really depends on the type of database
that you're talking about we bring in
writing this paper in the wake of the
revelations surrounding the Golden State
killer case where you might remember law
enforcement used a publicly accessible
genealogy website and that really
prompted us to take a look at the
current practices and we came to the
conclusion that in essence law
enforcement essentially has a de facto
Universal database already when you look
at the forensic databases combined with
all the public and private databases to
find the Golden State killer they
pretended to be a consumer submitted the
DNA and then found their relatives yeah
that's correct they
didn't need a subpoena or a warrant or
anything like that to find this person's
DNA no they did so completely without
court authorization as you mentioned
simply by pretending that the DNA was
theirs and uploading it under the ruse
that they were hoping to fill out their
family tree so to speak going back
almost 10 years now there have been op
eds there was one of the New York Times
there have been policy papers and
journals addressing this topic and
asking the question would a universal
DNA database for forensic purposes be
better than you know how law enforcement
uses genetic data is the Golden State
Killer case really what prompted you to
resurface this that's what God is
thinking about the issue but not only
that but also the rapid expansion of
forensic law enforcement databases a lot
of people might know CODIS but each
state maintains its own forensic
database and they're even creating now
what are called shadow databases that is
for profiles that might not meet the
criteria for the nationwide system but
that law enforcement might want to store
locally this raises a whole host of
privacy issues for a while it was people
who are arrested and people who are in
the prison system whose DNA profile is
taken into the database run by the
government but now it's swabbing people
they pull over in a traffic stop and
then putting that into their local
database yeah we've seen anecdotal
reports of someone might be stopped by
police and then asked to voluntarily
consent to provide a sample and although
it is in theory voluntary you can
imagine there might be some coercion
associated with that this is a good
description of the landscape right now
of how the police law enforcement
interacts with what DNA databases are
out there so what's the case for making
a universal one where everybody is in it
so in this article we argue that if
correctly implemented a universal system
would not only be a much more effective
law enforcement tool and reduce the need
to conduct these long range familial
searches but it also would be less
discriminatory and more protective of
privacy than the current system and
there's a number of reasons for that
yeah what do you mean by discriminatory
currently if you look at the forensic
databases they're predominantly
lower-income minority individuals that
are in these databases that's likely why
police have to resort to a resource like
GED match in the Golden State killer
case where you see that in terms of
direct-to-consumer genetic testing
databases databases that use that type
of direct-to-consumer data those
individuals are predominantly from
higher income brackets and predominantly
more white than your forensic databases
it'll make it less likely to only be
searching a certain swath of the public
and also give law enforcement access to
parts of the public that aren't
typically in these databases correct one
thing that really struck me about this
was thinking about genetic profiles from
ancestry calm or 23andme it's anything
they can find in your genetic profiles
are looking for medical who you're
related to all that stuff but if it were
this kind of forensic database it's
limited to like a certain set of loci on
the genome correct and that's critical
to our argument as you mentioned when
you're talking about data in the
healthcare or research or direct
consumer space you're talking about
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of genetic variations and they're often
coupled with personal information like
family medical histories what we're
talking about is collecting a very
limited subset of genetic information a
dozen or so markers for law enforcement
purposes
there's strictly for identification
purposes they're not to tell you what
color eyes someone has there to tell you
whether or not you have a certain number
of repeats in an area of a chromosome
correct and that type of information
generally reveals little to no sensitive
health information you mentioned
research and medical records just now so
how do those how are those used
currently by law enforcement are they
accessible well under HIPAA in most
circumstances a subpoena as opposed to a
warrant is all that is generally
required to access that information in
the research space it's a little
different recent law conveyed some extra
protections to research participants and
purports to assure individuals that
their data is immune from court orders
of that type however those are
automatically granted only to
research funded by the National
Institutes of Health and other HHS
entities and might leave some private
research unprotected well if there were
a universal database would you expect
that some of these other avenues that
the law enforcement has been using would
be cut off yes in our paper we make the
argument that with a universal system in
place since law enforcement needs would
be met Congress or lawmakers should
simultaneously severely severely
restrict the ability of law enforcement
to seek data from these other sources
what other protections would you
recommend if such a database were
instituted one of the central
protections that we call for and this is
related to the limited genetic profiles
is destruction of the physical samples
once they have been analyzed in the data
uploaded into the universal database so
this would be the cheek swab or the
actual spit in a cop that police might
collect and this is crucial because it
eliminates a main privacy concern when
you're talking about a universal system
and that is that the government might
have access to an individual's entire
genome if they had that sample and you
would be worried that retesting would
occur and that the genetic profile would
be expanded beyond what was originally
intended I think a lot of people will
come back to the universal nature of
this in this country in the u.s. there's
very little universal anything there
isn't a universal database of
fingerprints there isn't a universal
database of even driver's license photos
as far as I know so how do you see it
being taken up and discussed at the
cultural level certainly I think there's
going to be quite a knee-jerk reaction
as you mentioned we do not have many of
those national systems but we do have a
national social security number system
we do collect fingerprints and other
biometric data from individuals entering
this country I think it's premature to
disregard the idea completely especially
when you look at the current context and
the current system that we have do you
mean that people are their privacy is
amazing and very different and more
extensive ways than perhaps this
proposed system would so really
it's a combination of the ability of law
enforcement to get access to data in
research health care or
direct-to-consumer databases simply with
a subpoena combined with the current
makeup of forensic databases which tend
to be skewed toward disadvantaged
individuals well I think that it'll
probably be a very long process to get
anything like this in place but this
really does expose some issues with
what's going on right now with the
subpoena only level of protection and
that was really a central reason why we
chose to write the paper we felt it was
putting the idea of a universal forensic
database on the table would spur a long
overdue debate about the deficiencies of
the current system and more broadly our
societal commitments to fairness and
equal protection how do you propose that
samples be collected for a universal
database
well the ethical objections to mandating
that individuals who have done nothing
wrong
submit a DNA sample are certainly not
trivial there are a number of ways it
could be accomplished whether through a
sense of style effort or potentially
even through forensic profiling of
newborns whereby you already mandate
that they undergo some compulsory
medical tests we acknowledge that these
raise some serious ethical issues that
would certainly need to be debated
during the implementation phase and
ultimately resolved by lawmakers which
in this case would be Congress it's also
worth noting that concerns about
coercion or invasions of privacy did not
give legislators or for that matter the
Supreme Court pause when authorizing the
compelled collection of DNA from orestes
even for in many cases relatively minor
crimes thank you so much James James
hazel is a postdoctoral research fellow
at the Center for genetic privacy and
identity in community settings you can
read his Policy Forum at science mag org
and that concludes this edition of the
science podcast if you have any comments
or suggestions for the show write to us
at science podcast at AAAS o RG you can
subscribe to the show anywhere you get
your podcasts or you can listen on the
science website that science math or
gosh podcast to place an ad on the
science podcast contact mid-roll com
the show was produced by Sarah Crespi
and Megan Cantwell and edited by pada G
Jeffrey could compose the music on
behalf of science magazine and it's
publisher Blas thanks for joining us